There
are two aspects to this question.
The first is temperature.
Numerous studies throughout the last century
have shown that cold temperatures will not
increase your chance of becoming infected
by a cold virus.
Now that’s out of the way, let’s attack
the second aspect.
The fact that there is a “cold and flu season”,
and it does coincide with cooler temperatures.
The analytical side of me needs to break through
some societal tendencies before this second
aspect can be evaluated.
From my experience, when people get sick,
they tend to describe mild symptoms as “colds”
and severe ones as “the flu”.
Unfortunately, you can’t diagnose an illness
simply by the perceived severity of symptoms.
If any given group of people were exposed
to the same cold virus, many would have mild
to no symptoms, and some would have more severe
reactions.
The same can be said for flu viruses.
The distinction between the two also gets
blurred by some people’s tendency to over-exaggerate
their symptoms.
In truth, a person’s reaction to them aside,
these are two very different types of viruses.
There are over 200 different strains of “cold”
viruses, mainly made up of rhinoviruses (up
to 50%).
The average adult in the US will get 2-4 colds
per year.
The average child will get 6-8.
These types of viruses usually are associated
with mild symptoms.
Up to 25% of infected people won’t show
any symptoms at all.
Most won’t get a fever, and if you do, it
will be low-grade- around 100 degrees Fahrenheit.
Your Runny nose (thus rhinovirus) and cough
will tend to be mild.
These viruses primarily won’t transmit through
the air.
Instead, people become infected by coming
into direct contact with someone who has an
infection, or touch something that an infected
person touches.
Influenza, however, is a much more sinister
beast, affecting approximately 10% of the
US population every year.
This virus tends to start with sudden onset
of a higher fever between 100-104 degrees
Fahrenheit.
It then progresses into chills, headache,
muscle aches and a loss of appetite.
Flu’s can also lead to more serious conditions
like bronchitis and pneumonia.
Those whose immune systems might be compromised,
like the elderly or chronically ill, are at
risk of death.
Approximately 20,000 people a year die from
the flu, so maybe mom was right.
You will catch your death!
So why the increase in these illnesses in
the winter?
It seems this knowledge has been around for
many centuries.
The word influenza comes from an older Italian
phrase “influenza di freddo” or “influence
of the cold”.
The flu-season usually ranges from November
to March in the northern hemisphere (the coldest
months) and May to September in the lower.
In fact, in tropical climates, there tends
to be extremely low incidences of flu and
certainly no true “flu season”.
There are several contributing factors to
why cold temperatures increase influenza infection
rates, all of which seem to be well known
and promoted by health officials in numerous
publications.
The most common is that people tend to stay
indoors when the temperatures get colder.
This allows people to be in closer contact
with each other and therefore makes it easier
to pass the virus from person to person.
Another contributing factor could be that
in large parts of the country children are
going back to school and interacting more
with their fellow infected.
In fact, most epidemics can be traced back
to children.
The answer to this riddle lies in how the
influenza virus reacts to temperature and
humidity.
The virus is extremely stable in colder temperatures,
41 degrees Fahrenheit optimally.
The warmer you go, the less stable it becomes.
Around 86 degrees, the virus isn’t transmitted
at all.
Humidity also plays a very important role.
Influenza is primarily transmitted on the
droplets from your respiratory tract (cover
your mouth when you cough kids!)
The more humid the environment, the more water
is available for those droplets to “pick
up”.
The heavier the droplets become, the faster
they will fall to the ground and out of the
way of our mucus membranes.
In drier environments, those death droplets
hang around in the air longer for others to
breathe in.
In fact, one study showed that the virus was
best transmitted at a humidity of 20% and
not transmitted at all once the humidity reached
80%.
(And you thought moving to more tropical climates
when you get old and sick was just a bunch
of voodoo medicine!)
That same study showed animals transmit the
virus for a full two days longer at 41 degrees
F than they do at a room temperature of 68.
The conclusion was that a person’s respiratory
tract is colder and therefore the virus can
be more stable inside your mucus membranes.
So what does all this mean?
You are no more likely to get a cold in the
winter then you are in the summer.
The flu, however, is a different animal altogether.
You are more likely to get this virus in the
winter.
So just remember kids: wash your hands, cover
your mouth when you cough, and apparently
move to Florida when you retire.